the Trump administration's escalating
trade war with China is putting some
American farmers on uncertain ground in
response to u.s. tariffs China slapped a
25 percent tariff on US soybean last
week more Italian could be ahead
American soybean farmers are among the
businesses lately caught in the middle
of trade disputes the fight has also
affected motorcycle maker Harley
Davidson Dean Reynolds is at a soybean
farm in Esmond Illinois Dean good
morning good morning well China has been
the leading importer of US agricultural
goods for the last several years so this
trade dispute with Beijing has the owner
of this 800 acre spread in Illinois
worried about how it may change the
landscape of his business it
artificially raises our prices farmer
Paul Taylor isn't thrilled by the
prospect of tariffs but he's willing to
give president Trump's trade approach a
chance now though you think the
president knows what he's doing I hope
so I mean I'm given the benefit of the
doubt I think it's ok to shake things up
last Friday the Trump administration
imposed a 25% tariff on Chinese goods
worth thirty four billion dollars and
China immediately responded with its own
tariffs on US goods including soybeans
couldn't it also be an incentive to the
Chinese to buy more soybeans from say
Brazil well of course it is though
optimistic the third-generation farmer
has concerns in this case it's done to
modify behavior of our trading partners
will that work
I don't know they don't have a very good
record for that I just hope to god it
doesn't lead to any kind of
international recession we probably lost
last year 500 billion dollars in trade
to China President Trump has long spoken
about how he thinks China takes
advantage of the u.s. earlier this week
the president addressed farm trade
tweeting I am fighting for a level
playing field for our farmers and will
win when would you harvest this here on
Taylor's farm patience could be in much
shorter supply come fall when the
soybeans are ready to sell the price per
bushel is down
about 20% since March I'm over 90% price
than my 2018
soybeans so so you're set for 2018 yeah
kinda but 2019 bets are off and if there
is one word that could describe the
feelings down on the farm this year it
is uncertainty like when you grow crops
for a living
but you aren't really sure who's going
to buy them John Dean it looks beautiful
where you are in kind of a field field
of dreams there except when it comes to
tariffs right the field of uncertain
dreams yeah or something
Dean is outstanding in his field